we're here with the official Brainiac
character breakdown for injustice to now
this was taken from nether realms live
stream but since the game comes out next
Tuesday May 16th be sure to hit that
subscribe button to stay up to date with
all the latest on DC's premier fighting
game gameplay just can take a look let's
just start off with the house mobile
attacks were not sure so like you were
saying he uses tendrils for the most
part he has a few punches but you can
see is sweet it's down to is probably
the best down to in the history of
fighting it's pretty good that's good
yet um even it's for three he has a lot
of combos that start from very far he
can fight you pretty well in mid range
and right have to feel like he's have to
worry about what you do kind of keep you
out right so what strings would you say
are like some of his like real bread and
butter sort of strings you always went
well is for two is a very fast advancing
high and the interstate so we'll go all
the ways that he'll end up close or not
the away if it hits his back one ends in
an overhead and has takes up a lot of
space and it's pretty quick uh-huh he
has this for one which is a low he does
not have a way to like to start a combo
of a bounce but it's you know it's
pretty good damage and it knocks you
away you'll notice the knocking away
thing is very common error for his
attacks it keeps you on this right yeah
and just keep standing walking around he
can kind of keep throwing that out and
make you like have to deal with the
crowd is jump attacks uh have a ton of
range
he's jumped to is basically he's like
fully protected himself
that's awesome cross up yeah so
archetype wires what would you say I
would say he's kind of a flimsy
character like a mid-range
space control character East okay he's
not the fastest he doesn't have the best
like recovery and stuff but he
outrageous you for sure no one's really
gonna out range your maternal attacks
with punishing pretty well yeah yeah but
punishes you very well you kind of walk
back if you miss anything you're a lot
of trouble right and then this is all
complemented by special moves let's just
go into them sure we'll start with this
docks drill which is a great like combo
ender gets you damage with it if it
needs to down one is that one's notable
for a ton of range that's actually a
luck not many down ones are low didn't
know that yeah I should have known that
right on the meter bird one is actually
safe and you can see I'm block or push
in it
he wasn't blogging so he's totally safe
so maybe one of you is like I said his
moves don't have the best recovery you
can do something and just do the meter
burn Doc's drill and you get like the
classic two and one little chip bit at
the end there right yeah safe chick and
if you do it you know you only ever
write you're going to build a little bit
of your own block it's always good he's
standing three like that then he has
cheap ultimate anti-air another greedy
entire you know he's gonna have to have
a move like that with those technical oh
yeah I'm so cool he can be driven for
additional damage and take them
that is so awesome thank you pretty much
you can't jump at him like if he even
have an inkling the opponent's gonna
jump but you're gonna get hosed right
and then that totally complements what
we do this place fell so he controls the
ground and you're like okay and what do
you do when you're getting out neutral
you start jumping right but doing that
against him is incredibly deadly so he's
gonna keep you on the ground or the DXS
wearing his weaknesses wait where does
he where do you find really good ends
with Brainiac well I would say his walk
speed walking in is not the fastest his
recoveries not the fastest he's good
with punishing but if if he whips an
attack he's in a lot of trouble he has
to kind of use his meter to stay safe
like otherwise he's going to be
punishable so he's kind of a sort of a
high-risk character but he really
regulates you wanting to play you have a
very patient very methodical and if you
can't match his pace if you're trying to
rush in and he's keeping away you're a
lot of trouble Gavin he can catch you
slipping a lot and he's able to
capitalize it because although there's a
lot of his moves begin from that far
away so it's not like he can't get big
punishes off of that right brain caught
you slipping yeah he also has the solar
barge going very very fast reaches
almost across the whole screen and the
meter per one is again it's safe so for
a bar meter if you can actually be very
safe and you'll see again he'll actually
push you back so it's an interesting
thing where normally being pushed back
is not good to you offensively but his
range is so strong it actually helps a
lot of opponents will die because
they're basically trying to they have to
keep coming in right I mean he can keep
just whittling you down it you back
every time you get in if you don't win
the exchange he's gonna knock you full
screen again and you just gotta like
work your way back to him slowly this is
what I call why not move which is
nothing bad is gonna happen just do it
do it there fullscreen and he goes back
to his owning game and if it's blocked
they're pushed back and he's safe so why
not yeah especially if you kind of like
some people have a panic button or
they're like get off me move and you're
like I'm stuck I don't know what to do
if you can do that like you'll at least
reset situation right go again for him
though like you start pushing him closer
and closer to the corner you're starting
to nullify more of his range exactly so
right but then you get to the point
where Brainiac pushes you into the
corner if you can slowly get it that
corner he can just stand there again cuz
you're gonna want to jump out of the
corner and he can just sit away one you
and like
that move yeah it's it's very risky
let's talk about some more of his
specials
well and then I think one of those big
big specials we talked about mobility he
actually has a type which is very
unusual for a ground-based character so
he can kind of go in the air he could be
a vertically confident it's very unique
to but based on where you do it and
angle the trajectory kind of
investigates how high or low you are and
you'll notice it can also autocorrect so
you can jump over you you can I pick
over you penny okay and then you'll
absently always go where the opponent
native Aaron goes the other way and the
comment of this in addition to his jump
he has a air jump where easy this time
to Romans and you'll actually go in the
air and you can control the distance
like this is the Far version you can
drop and drop down in and did you go
down you can do is normal attacks from
here and you can actually do the dot fit
so you can do fun stuff like you can
actually go over them and then I kick
around yep one of the things too is so
Criss crossing over them and kind of mix
them up and then you can also kind of
immediately dive kick when you land like
hit low and immediately go into the you
guys quick overhead yeah very punishable
but it's one of those kind of like once
you put the fear in your opponent you're
going to be kind of risky and you get
bored yeah you will have to unlock
commit to the meter burglar yeah so you
aren't safe but you know it's very very
tricky so he's really a character that
will do great on the ground he'll do
great if you try to jump and then if you
can't jump that frees up him to start
jumping and that's when he starts going
crazy all over the screen i mobility and
that's when he gets in vixens going this
it's kind of you can think of it like on
the ground
it's very methodical very slow-paced
very keeping you out
but in the air he goes nuts that's his
office his ground offenses not really
that strong like he doesn't have a lot
of lows and overheads he mostly just
throws you or just stays safe with this
but in the air that's when he can fix
you up all the cross so if you mentioned
just jump to the cross up they do is a
dashes dashboards and Becker oh yeah
yeah yeah you can see he covers a ton of
distances for his back - is not the
greatest I'm just four - is great let's
talk about scary power this character
power is super interesting yeah he calls
these little beta bombs um he had drones
right there you can do a round one in
the air one the biggest thing too is you
can hold it down
so when he can summon it but not use it
so he's steve has the button held right
now so while you can while you're
playing you can do all kinds of other
combos still holding it choose when to
let go so you can do a lot of tricky
stuff cross up situations and did you
really mess with your opponent you can
hold it for a long time yeah yeah
sometimes you play in your opponent will
forget you held it yeah then the last
minute will come out or you could tricky
shoot it cross them up with the swing
and the dive cake let it go you can
throw them before the drone will hit
them and you can hold both the bomb and
the straight one you can also use it
rapidly you don't have to use it for
centers it also can just act as a very
fast projectile you can do form rapidly
you can hold one for however long get
your mix up and immediately throw
another one now another one crazy but it
does have it you have a timer there the
bomb I guess you do you get about four
or you can space them out like you can
do one - a little more
- could be a simple projectile or that's
right a lot of ways open and this can
make some of those moves that are
already pretty decent even better like
you see he has this combo starter and
you can't really get a battery or
anything really juicy so it'll just kind
of do a simple combo nothing fancy but
he has this out you're not there right
now if you have it ready you can see it
hits release it then get your bacteria
there's many different stuffs with one
thing that Steve and I both had in
common is because you do have to hold it
so both of us are like older players so
we both immediately kind of like we when
I play class we're like I also play claw
so as soon as we play him I immediately
go like claw style because you got to
hold the button now yeah yeah so we're
both like oh we both were right on the
same page if I get lost I'll manually
1995 yeah it's like a natural looking
back as soon as you're like I got to
hold this button alright that's just how
I play it yeah awesome so we also do
have is there no there's more super
super super bear super hit the throw
statement supers boss
I love this shot what I fear cinematic
shot see is just is the ship kind of
coming through the clouds yeah he's so
ominous and IR that and I love them you
really want to sell that that's awesome
oh it did hit a great job sells well so
I think ultimately he's kind of
interesting because he can be super fast
they experience we have those varying
seams that's why a lot of setups or you
can just kind of hold back it out range
everyone great cool let's talk about
some we loaded with different gear
loadout did so I'm very excited you get
your sheets I do I got it okay
Steve Wright's sheets which I guess are
down my operation but I don't even this
time we prep
well Brainiac would do that you as was
as much information as possible
collected and destroy you right away
after so we'll start off well you can
see right here you'd like big shoulder
pads the gold color you picked this out
I did I like how and I really like the
tendril color that's really cool Goldust
pivot yeah a little bit when a character
customization yeah so let's start off he
has a harpoon you'll pull them in crush
I like them it's a good combo ender it's
a good full screen check and the meter
burn one he actually gets accomplished
they'll hold them in and not do the beat
down and it Inc it's a combos so earlier
I was saying if one of his main
weaknesses is on the ground he's not
really like a combo machine other than
using his character power he is with
this slow down so if his air mobility is
not particularly strong in a particular
matchup and you're having a lot of
trouble opening them up
it's not working this could be a great
tool to use and not you know now he is
accomplice and let's do a quick little
jab like you did do it down three there
you go full combo you got the old wake
up then and we also gave him his tendril
shell and this is actually like a parry
or a absorption you can hold this down
and then if the opponent attacks you can
electrocuted and gets calm that's cool
can kind of props here real quick cuz I
know you love props
I love props you are able to go through
training mode menu screens quicker than
anyone I've ever seen
why not ever eyes memorize don't
actually read it yes beyond rice
leftover one better my cords quickly and
then I mean that's amazing you're like
waiting for the game to catch up to you
whenever it changes I absolutely freak
out yeah trigger he does happen
throughout the development of a game
they streamed on it real very much a
player so yeah this is be good for a
defensive let's say it's you're playing
a particular matchup where the keep out
is just not working you're gonna have to
play up close and he's not the best at
it
you gotta have this new defensive option
that I couldn't sound it scares the
opponent from attacking you and shacking
is benefit because any can space you out
and that's exactly so he can actually go
is facing because they're gonna
different awesome so one more load on
one more loadout check your notes you're
the bad I'm calling you after checking
your net it's a little weird you got a
good but what you talking about old
table feels like you're exposing the
business I that's only okay faith this
is really cool when we gave him the ion
cannon summons a can move around very
very fast takes up the whole sky looks
like he's actually starting from the sky
but from his ship let's Roman shut the
skull ship and if you meet a burden you
can actually control it
he gets campos off this and puts your
opponent on air right
trust me he gets confidence you can
actually hit him too right
trust me trust me it works
yeah look at this look at that like just
beastly you can do anything yeah yeah it
just doesn't respond damage and this
really complements the screen control I
mean it's it's harder to get better
screen controls and he beam shooting
from the sky's trigger viewpoint it is I
would say the game timing out yet and I
still I think you're not even the top
100 brainiacs that's probably true there
are people who are theory fighting at
home who are better radiant that's
that's probably a possibly be so that um
we gave them a lot which replaces the
shoulder barge with a slide so this is
an actual low hitting move it's super
fast goes full screen and if you
interpret it it's an immediate overhead
it's low overhead super quick and this
is safe on block like the shoulder the
beater burns so it's getting very good
waking the tag very good fullscreen Ted
you can use it for kind of mix-ups if
you want
it's pretty hard to block real quick
when you say full screen check for those
who don't maybe know what that term mean
kinda explain that real quick well
essentially a check would be a move
where let's say Superman you're Superman
and you're kind of doing your laces a
check would mean this basically tells
you I'm gonna do this and you gotta look
for I'm checking it man so that is a
four it'll make me slow down my lasers
because I have then you're the scary for
the slide keeps you from place so you're
keeping me out and if I do this now you
know I'm willing to do that and then I
can start dashing up and throwing you
I can join my my jump attacks and stuff
like that since it's basically letting
it's basically an option that I can do
it anytime but you got to keep your eyes
out Ketcham cool so those are the
Brainiac gear moves we're going to show
he does have some more but we don't
wanna show everything again and you'll
be able to see those very very soon
because the game comes out on Tuesdays
and I'm guessing people be playing mine
at night and we'll have some fun there
absolutely well yeah Mike sir thank you
Mike Portillo at zigzag on twitter at
two genes two days - geez thank you